[Musique]
halloween à la maison c'est aussi
l'occasion de passer une soirée
cocooning devant la télé mélanie poker
bonsoir vous avez sélectionné quelques
idées de films plus ou moins effrayant
et oui des films pour ce fort par une y
en a bon nombre il ya massacre à la
tronçonneuse l'exorciste hérédité
shining ou encore ce film culte avec un
titre tout trouvé halloween réalisé par
john carpenter l'histoire de michael
myers un jeune homme qui s'échappe d'un
asile psychiatrique et qui s'en prend
aux adolescents de la ville mais si on
est facilement effrayé pour halloween
on peut aussi regarder des films drôles
et oui les froussards comme moi peuvent
aussi passer une soirée halloween est ce
qu'avec son bilan de sortie en 2009 fait
place au second degré dans un monde
plein de zombies woody harrelson jesse
eisenberg emma stone et abigail breslin
tente de survie ou encore shaun of the
dead là aussi des zombies là aussi de la
survie et surtout de sacrés fous rires
jaunes et aides sont deux amies qui se
retrouvent dans une banlieue de londres
totalement enregisté
[Musique]
c'est quoi le rappeler à la tête des
salaires de pars sud
voilà les chais livre parce que je laime
d'accord et ne bougeait plus et alors si
on veut plutôt profiter d'une soirée en
famille ont été commencées comment on va
voir aussi il ya beaucoup de films ce
que les plus jeunes ils ont aussi le
droit de se faire peur ou du monde de
frissonner qui n'a pas enfants eu
quelques sursauts et que les gremlins
casper la famille adams ou encore les
noces funèbres
plus récemment il y a eu au tel
transylvanie c'est l'histoire de l'hôtel
du comte dracula ou les monstres et
leurs familles peuvent vivre sans leur
vie sans être ennuyés par les humains
jusqu'à ce que l'on de l'un d'entre eux
débarquent
[Musique]
je faisais de l'escaladé avec quelques
potes et j'ai entendu parler d'un
château mortels
d'ailleurs en parlant de morton je capte
jure j'ai une tuerie la soirée peut même
permettre de voir les suites deux autres
volets sont sortis en 2015 et en 2018
merci mélanie pour ces quelques idées
une liste bien sûr non exhaustive